85 mille euros c'est le montant de prêts
d'honneur sans intérêt des trois
convention récemment signée le fonds de
prêts d'honneur est financé par yveline
coopération internationale et
développement
toutes ces initiatives verront le jour
au cameroun et au sénégal dans 7 des
actifs d'aia diaspora ils ont participé
au développement de l'économie de notre
département n'oublions pas la vallée de
la seine et donc nous avons aujourd'hui
aussi un devoir de retour vers leur pays
d'origine
ces trois initiatives ont été examinés
notamment par l'association a phase
spécialiste de l'accompagnement et du
financement des entreprises dans les
yvelines
a phase a sélectionné les trois lauréats
suivant plusieurs critères où s'élabore
la viabilité économique d'une part le la
suffisance de financement pour arriver à
atteindre l'objectif est la personnalité
des créateurs on tient beaucoup à
l'humain nous sommes pas une banque
nous sommes on fait des prêts d'honneur
à une personne d'ici trois ans ces
initiatives pourront avoir généré 60
emplois au cameroun et au sénégal et six
emplois dans les yvelines
l'objectif du projet c'est tout
simplement aujourd'hui de permettre un
développement
de la fait que notamment des cameron qui
sera le pilote pour le démarrage de ce
projet de faciliter l'accès au plus
grand nombre à des techniques modernes
de construction à des outils mécanisée
pour augmenter la productivité agricole
et augmenter notamment le revenu des
petits agriculteurs
autre projet qui a reçu un prêt
d'honneur de 30000 euros une bourse de
stage de 5000 euros diaspora santé
l'ambition de cette mutuelle est clair
multiplier par 10 le taux d'accès aux
soins de santé en afrique sur cinq ans
nous faisons le pari que sur les 5,8
millions
deux personnes de la diaspora si chacun
prenait en charge un membre de sa
famille nous passerons de 2% à 21 % de
couverture santé aux comores cette
assurance santé est ouverte au cameroun
depuis fin 2010 est la côte d'ivoire le
sénégal et la guinée suivront